thank you
[Music]
okay so there's a little situation
that's going on at this expensive
residential complex that has a community
pool oh no
um everybody
there's this classic situation where uh
some white ladies kind of going on a
racist tirade of course and they call it
they're calling her poolside Karen
because she lives in the complex as well
but she's yelling at some Mexican
residents for having too many Mexicans
in the pool
of course there should be there should
be a sign sometimes we take it too far
it says only 15 people can fit here
everybody is okay but she's like it's
like a thing
the girl who was filming her while she
was like going on her crazy ass thing uh
she's the Mexican girl and she's filming
it and then uh she released it and it
went kind of viral yeah and then now the
lady in it is complaining that she had
edited it and didn't include the parts
where everyone was calling her a white
[__]
and she's complaining about her argument
better she's
claiming that they had physically
attacked her first and that she was
scratched so hard that the fake nails
came off and then she grabbed them and
has them in her hand in the video let me
see it's pretty interesting what the f
all they have is her hold on before we
see it
do you think the camera's gonna be
better or not it's gonna be hot or not
probably ugly ugly overweight ugly I
don't think I've ever seen a hot carrot
yeah me neither she's in her late 40s
let's just say that oh okay so what do
you think it's gonna be hot that's not
old
I usually
other people
party the pool
oh
she's hot oh she's touching my phone
[__]
go back down to Denver
I don't even know
she said she said you don't even know
what Hermes is
um
right now about that comment neither do
I
what is Hermes it's that brand that's
spelled Hermes sorry to break it to you
lady but if you guys are living in the
same Community you're probably not that
rich yeah yeah so this well what if they
are rich dude whoa Joe
yeah why can't they be working hard this
building has an average rent
6 500 a month for like for the unit yeah
so it's 6 500 a month it's like they're
selling drugs it's no Mexican can afford
this [__] so she's calling them
low-class slime
but she looks like white trash though
she doesn't look damn does she look like
her she that's what I'm saying it's like
she's white trash Behavior that's her
yeah but she's yeah you know what she
would say it like that she said I'm
saying something right now okay yeah
she's a [__] yeah she was yelling on
that she actually stuck in a hater but
she can't get it
he's just [__] dry looking [__]
turned his carrot into a garden okay
she looks [__] thirsty she looks
thirsty
don't do that to me man show this little
girl
that's her yeah even better oh my God
what do you do protect yourself
wow that's for [__] crumbs
someone put this man in jail oh my God
my brown Queen
[Laughter]
what you did not like 10 times bigger
well no wonder she's upset yeah she's so
[__] hot ass girl at the porch like
[__] you [__] fine [__] so she so
the Mexican girl she's a hairdresser the
white lady is a feng shui expert shut
the [__]
you know what I think the real story is
her husband was probably staring at her
yes
yes they're jealousy yes because the
husband was on the phone some guy was on
the phone like uh yeah
doing this zooming in her
lightness
recording this whole [__] situation
I got the whole thing right
[Laughter]
you see that look at her picture
white chicks you know the movie oh yeah
do you know what Hermes is yeah yeah it
is yeah like a nikoi salad
why do they always go with that like
that's a [__] you don't even know
what a nurse is the thing is that girl
who's filming replies and going I'm
wearing her meds and her shoes were
literally her mess oh my God you don't
even know what our best is I wonder how
much like feng shui experts make a year
yeah so the uh it's like you go to your
like someone's house and you could
rearrange the room in the office so it
feels it's like some Chinese art so this
is five checks bro
it's always is that what it is it's
getting the Vibes right oh my God but
apparently she's an expert at that AKA
she's just unemployed if you're white
her [__] feng shui is off though dude
look at her she's appropriating yeah
look how [__] [__] up her [__]
she got so much anxiety up in that [__]
yeah what's going on she's claims that
she's the one who was attacked by the
group of course because her husband's
horny
women
she claims that right where it cuts off
there that they jumped her at that point
she should have been reaching for the
phone
exactly I think you should desert get
Slappy reach for someone's phone and
they were the Mexican family was calling
the cops and they didn't show up for
like hours but eventually they came and
arrested her
Colorado I was just saying like go back
to Denver or whatever yeah but also like
maybe like a small town come on stay in
Denver where you minorities live we also
like
Colorado but also like work a little
harder and buy yourself a house with a
pool yeah you [__] white trash
problem
it's in Colorado in a place called Alta
Green Mountain so it's probably like a
Richard sounds nice that's my thing when
it comes to like this is the thing about
living in apartments bro it's like
people don't understand like you're
sharing all of this you know no one owns
any of this we are all sharing this yeah
you know until you work hard enough to
get the [__] out you know and have your
own space and then you don't have to
[__] control the space and fight with
everybody my dad would I remember when
we lived in apartments and these [__]
again another
yeah baby
baby
oh yeah dude God damn she looks A2
um
she both
no you already committed bro keep your
crumbs bro dude
I [__] up boo boo
[__] up what were you saying not dude
like when I lived in an apartment it's
always that one caring lady just like
they didn't care at seven in the morning
ah you need to move your parking spot
you overpark that's like dude what the
[__] is wrong with you they don't know
how to share and my dad instead of
flipping out he was saying I'm just
gonna do overtime for the whole three
months so I'll win to get the hell out
of here buy a house like they that's
what they say they were like we're just
gonna work harder yeah to get the [__]
out yeah right because we're just gonna
keep living and bumping heads and some
people just don't think like that they
just I don't know what they're doing you
just work extra hard so you could get
away from people like that yeah simple
as that so it's one of those situations
where she didn't believe that the
Mexicans actually lived there and she
was demanding what a [__] suck my dick
white lady and she was it says that uh
she was heard calling the group I would
love to see her scolding them from the
restaurant
[__] Mexican party that's so [__]
up like even if they were hosting a
family party still like to be like
[__] Mexican parties
why do you gotta [__] say Mexican
party
that's a white Denver yes dude that's
what that is
in the sun she's like what the [__] are
they having a Mexican party
next you need it coming right now the
[__] Mexican Mafia is swimming in the
swimming pool are you serious they're
making carnita asada and I'm not
standing for this [__] so she asked them
straight up like you do you guys live
here and then uh the girl was like yes I
do and she was like well I need to see
your key fob you don't need to see Yo
like a Karen moment have you guys ever
got it's so rare actually I think we
look you guys never had when's the last
time not anymore no not anymore because
they know not in the modern day not in
the modern day just just this weekend
there was this guy uh this this white
dude um my nephew I think had the his
iPad a little too loud and he was a
kenron oh was staring at my cut at my
nephew and I didn't even realize and
then like uh he said something and then
I I finally saw him I'm like are you
okay he was like uh what do you say he
said it's obnoxiously loud for a public
place shut the [__] up dude I was like
what do you mean a public place and then
he paid his check and he left what a
[__] idiot there's a white dude with
a man bun where were you guys eating
were you guys Brazilian barbecue are you
[__] kidding me he was so pissed that
it was loud for public what was loud one
of our nephews is an iPad what it was
even loud are you [__] and they were
like singing happy birthday and there
was music and [__] and this [__] guy
I was like Ugh
I think some people don't understand
that like everyone else has a different
level of like what is Chill like so they
think that their idea of what is common
sense should be the number one rule yeah
so they think like everyone else should
follow their Common Sense
dude you just gotta learn how to [__]
coexist like some things aren't the
thing they're doing crazy obnoxious and
that one when everyone the whole
apartment complex comes out they're like
dude these guys are [__] playing
music till three in the morning I mean
that's pretty crazy right and if the
whole apartment complex agrees on it
then maybe do something but if you're
the trying to be like the sheriff in
town and do that [__] because
well if they don't do something who will
yeah but they're often wrong yeah where
how hey
I actually did have a [__] care
moment I was at the airport oh here we
go Airport's always Karen's an airport
yes and then you know how they separate
the line from like um when they pouring
Ridge there's a yes yeah I know through
B group right and then so um I had a
first class ticket but I was I was
running kind of late right and then this
lady
was like
trying to tell me like oh they're only
calling first class first yeah
and then I'm like I am and I walked by
oh and I was like it didn't register
until I got down I was thinking oh she
probably thought I was cutting and I'm
like why did she think that and it was
like oh yeah she didn't think you could
afford it I could afford it 100 because
of how I look I look homeless yeah
call the border patrol yeah but that
must be the best [__] feeling knowing
that oh this [__] has no idea
like she don't even know
okay okay you just let them run their
mouth and you just know I'm about to
pull [__] and draw four right now [__]
and then you're like okay the cops show
up everybody shows up Sir can we see
your pets sure bam oh my God I didn't
know he stole it
like registered until I sat down that
and I got in my chair and I was like
wait a minute because it was so I was
like who the [__] does that who the [__]
looks at you and assumes like oh wait
it's not your turn yet and it's like it
is my turn [__] but like in my head I
didn't even think that yeah are you
[__] TSA what the [__] passenger yeah
she was waiting oh my God she was like
the front yeah older white lady but I
thought I thought it was because she
thought I was cutting yeah yeah so I was
just like no it is my turn once again
mind your own [__] business yeah but
I didn't know that until I sat down I
was like oh she didn't think yeah that's
why she did that did you blow her kiss
when she walked past you no I was in the
I love that feeling you realized no I
was going in yeah my own hallway so I
went through and then I go down
oh I like that you don't mingle with the
peasants you're a peasant yeah
foreign